have you ever thought about where your leftover
food goes after you throw it in the trash
or the consequences that it has for our planet
in the u.s alone about 37 million tons of
discarded food were brought to landfills in 2015
that's equal to the weight of 100 empire state
buildings in landfills food scraps and other
organic material are broken down by bacteria in
the absence of oxygen which produces methane a
potent greenhouse gas with even greater capacity
to trap heat in our atmosphere than carbon dioxide
composting is an eco-friendly alternative to
discarding our food waste with three important
advantages first composting allows food scraps
to degrade in the presence of oxygen meaning no
methane is produced second composting mimics
natural nutrient recycling processes breaking
down biodegradable materials to produce organic
fertilizer a sustainable alternative to synthetic
fertilizers that require high amounts of fossil
fuel energy to produce third composting diverts
waste from landfills preserving natural ecosystems
that would otherwise be cleared for landfill use
and the best part you can
compost in your own backyard
click the link in the description to learn more
you